on this Thursday night the penalties
keep piling up for Hockey Canada more
sponsors turn their backs over the
organization's refusal to act I hope
that they understand the message and
leave before they burn it to the ground
plus what the prime minister is
proposing YouTube tag tactics the hidden
way the federal conservative leader
promoted his videos to misogynist I
corrected the problem as soon as I it
became known to me Mr Speaker Global
News investigates shooting rampage the
cold-blooded attack at a nursery in
Thailand inflation frustration the Bank
of Canada Governor tells me interest
rates will keep Rising can you say
anything to reassure Canadians and
goredness gracious pumping out the
pumpkin spice is there no stopping it
global national with Donna Friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the intensifying pressure
on the senior leadership of Hockey
Canada what started as a trickle of
sponsors backing away has led to a flood
and the prime minister is now floating
the idea of creating a whole new
organization to replace Hockey Canada
all of this stems from the handling of
serious sex assault claims and a secret
slush fund to pay out multi-million
dollar settlements to alleged victims of
sexual assault Hockey Canada has
completely lost the confidence of
Canadians it's not like there's
something extraordinarily special about
the people at Hockey Canada that means
they're the only people in the country
that can run an organization like this
it is hard to keep track of how many
longtime sponsors are cutting ties with
the organization and they're not pulling
any punches about why they're walking
away from what were in some cases
Partnerships that existed for decades
Mike Armstrong has our top story tonight
I'm the first female chair of if Hockey
Canada was trying to improve its image
with Tuesday's Committee hearing that
hasn't happened instead of helping it's
hurt since that appearance sponsors have
been jumping ship and not without laying
some heavy criticism in statements Telus
says it's deeply disheartened by the
lack of action Tim Hortons deeply
disappointed in the lack of progress and
Scotiabank says the time for change is
long overdue Canadian Tire statement
Thursday didn't beat around the bush the
company says it's decided to end its
partnership with Hockey Canada because
it can no longer confidently move
forward together well if corporate
sponsors are being tough on Hockey
Canada's board the pressure out of
Ottawa is brutal I hope that they
understand the message and leave before
they burn it to the ground the sports
Minister saying she hopes the board
doesn't wait too long to the Prime
Minister proposing perhaps Hockey Canada
be replaced with the new Canada hockey
it is inconceivable that Folks at Hockey
Canada continue to dig in
the board has been under Fire since
Revelations about how it handled group
sexual assaults by players with the
national team in the Fallout the federal
government has frozen its funding
companies are pulling sponsorships and
provincial organizations are starting to
pull out as well that the board has held
on this long
is leaving some observers in disbelief I
do not know how at this point with all
of the backlash anyone with good
conscious would stay now the bleeding
continues Imperial oil esso's parent
company announced Thursday afternoon
it's polling support of the men's
program including the World Junior
tournament but while the hockey Canada
brand is taking a hit experts say it
likely wouldn't be permanent hockey's
importance in this country means
sponsoring the sport still makes sense
from a marketing perspective and
sponsors would be back like Armstrong
Global News Montreal
in Saskatchewan the RCMP has absolved
one of the brothers initially accused in
the mass murders in that Province last
month investigators now say Damien
Sanderson was murdered by his brother
miles they also say miles is solely
responsible for all 11 murders that
happened on September 4th on the James
Smith Cree Nation and in the nearby
community of weld in Saskatchewan police
say they do believe Damien played a role
in the initial planning
evidence collected and analyzed by
investigators to date have determined
Damien was involved in the initial
planning and preparation for the attacks
on September 4th
we are still investigating the extent of
Damien's involvement
police say the night before the killings
two officers entered a home looking for
Damien Sanderson they've since
determined he was there but say officers
didn't recognize him at the time because
the only photo they had of him was from
2014. investigators also say the
Sanderson brothers were involved in at
least three assaults that were not
initially reported to police Damien
sanderson's wife Skye spoke exclusively
with global news tonight she says it
hurts to know her husband was killed by
his brother but she is glad her kids now
know the truth
I have closure and
I'm in shock that his brother would even
do that to him and I hope his family
understands
what are you coming to my family
more information is expected to be
released next year during a Coroner's
inquest
now to a global news investigation it
has found the Federal leader of the
opposition Pierre pauliev has been using
a hidden tag on dozens of his YouTube
videos for years a tag that appeals to a
misogynistic men's Rights Movement the
tag mgtow stands for men going their own
way the tags were scrubbed as soon as
Global News asked pauliev's office to
explain Abigail Beeman brings us the
exclusive story
the butter on the bread that's up 17
Justin for four and a half years
embedded into dozens of Pierre pauliev
YouTube videos about everything from the
price of breakfast to the Queen's death
the queen had a special place in our
hearts a hidden tag not visible to
viewers but helping promote it to a
certain audience
mgtow it stands for men going their own
way men who want to completely cut out
women from their lives and there's
engagement in the so-called online
manosphere of other male Supremacy
groups including in cells which many
Canadians learned about for the first
time after the deadly 2018 Toronto van
attack where in cells are looking to
have forced relations men going the
their own way want to be separated by
women but validate their position by how
feminists have taken over jobs or
defined the woke society and those kind
of things so there can be some crossover
but not very much if if it were not for
Global News we would not have learned
that the conservative leader has been
purposefully using his videos to appeal
to far-right misogynistic online motion
I condemn this organization and I
corrected the problem as soon as I
became known to me [ __ ] within hours
of global news questioning the tags the
opposition Leader's office removed them
liberals call on polyev to apologize
this is really really dangerous and I'm
so I'm actually shaking I'm so
disappointed he's definitely you know
evokes this anti-woke idea which appeals
to many of these groups and so we could
see that perhaps they were trying to woo
That Base but I am shocked that it was
something that was so blatant no apology
in the house with Jabs about the prime
minister's record instead dressed up in
racist costumes for which he has not
ever come fully to account and he drove
many women of his own caucus out of the
party and out of parliament all together
Global News has learned the
conservatives tried to figure out who
was initially responsible for the tagged
but decided that was impossible ending a
very quick internal investigation
Abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa
ballots are now being counted in the
leadership race for Alberta's governing
United conservative party and later
tonight albertans will find out who will
be their next Premier seven candidates
are looking to replace Jason Kenney who
has forced out as leader earlier this
year the winner will immediately become
Premier designate until an election is
held if as is widely expected Danielle
Smith wins tonight she'll need to call a
by-election quickly she is the only
candidate who doesn't hold a seat in the
legislature there is shock and grief in
Thailand tonight after a man stormed a
daycare center killing at least 37
people including 24 children it happened
in a rural community about eight hours
Northeast of Bangkok the attack is
believed to be one of the world's worst
mass killings of children in recent
history carried out by a lone suspect as
Crystal gemancing explains the man at
the center of it is a former police
officer
the children at a rural daycare in
Thailand were napping when an armed man
forced his way in
he used his feet to kick in the window
then he shot at the door I thought he
got inside I ran to the kitchen behind I
was in shock I didn't know what to do
the knife that he brought it was like
for cutting grass it was curved
authorities identified the attacker as
Pena cam rap the 34 year old father was
a police Sergeant recently fired over
drug allegations
police say the majority of children were
stabbed to death at least 37 lives were
ended in the attack the youngest victim
was just two years old after his violent
Rampage at the daycare authorities say
the former police officer went home
where he killed his family before ending
his own life
the lead first responder at the main
scene saying we are used to seeing a
large number of bodies we've been
through it before but this incident is
the most harrowing of all they are
little kids who were still sleeping the
Deputy Prime Minister offered some
comfort to relatives waiting for news in
the emergency department
all of the victims who were injured are
in good hands with the doctors at this
hospital he pledged however anyone
needing more care would be transferred
to a larger Center
meanwhile The Wider Community is
fighting to comprehend the scale of the
violence
Crystal gomancing Global News London
in California the search for a family of
four including a baby girl abducted on
Monday has ended in tragedy police say a
farm worker found the bodies of the
eight-month-old her parents and an uncle
in a rural area this morning security
cameras had captured the family being
kidnapped and forced into a vehicle by a
man armed with a gun outside their
trucking business police have detained a
48-year-old suspect
the prime minister of Greece wants
closer cooperation among European allies
to stop migrants making perilous sea
Crossings there have been two more
shipwrecks in the last 24 hours a vessel
carrying roughly 40 migrants capsized
off the Greek Island of Lesbos earlier
this morning killing at least 18 people
mostly women and late Wednesday night 80
people including 18 children were
rescued after their boat ran aground
trapping many people between towering
Cliffs and crashing waves
the American president is taking a major
step towards the decriminalization of
marijuana Joe Biden issued a blanket
pardon today for anyone convicted
federally of simple possession of pot
and he's urging State Governors to
follow his lead the pardons will clear
about 6 500 people convicted between
1992 and 2021. Biden promised to do this
in the last election and decriminalizing
marijuana is gaining support in the U.S
The Strain on Canada's supply chain
coming up the potential solution that
might ease congestion
foreign
seems to be going up these days the cost
of food of energy interest rates and
inflation it's hard to know how to make
Financial plans for the future now a new
report says Canada's supply chain is
approaching its Breaking Point the
national supply chain task force says
governments and Industry must keep
things moving by targeting delays and
choke points as Eric Sorensen explains
efficient Supply chains can help make
life more affordable
if a car is missing one small
semiconductor that car and an entire
industry can be held up from medical
equipment to children's pain relievers
Canada's Supply chains by land and sea
and air have been plugged up and are in
desperate need of an overhaul says a new
task force report if we want to improve
Canadian life we need to have to be
better trade Partners Canada's supply
chain woes came to the fore during the
pandemic with blocked borders and labor
shortages but the economy still feels
the effect from insufficient supplies
and now inflation climate change and
weather disasters disrupt Supply chains
as does geopolitics from sanctions on
Russia to food shortages out of Ukraine
the report says what Canada can do is
ease Port container congestion and labor
shortages and create a new supply chain
office to coordinate strategy that
government work with industry to
identify choke points and and weak
weaknesses where infrastructure need
needs to be developed or improved
Ottawa says change is coming to make
Canadian life more affordable we are
going to ease congestion in bottlenecks
at ports use digital technology
technology in the supply chain and
modernize regulations to make it easier
and more efficient to move Goods but the
supply chain is just one area of the
economy hit hard this year the price of
food and the price of gas have caused
inflation to soar a new home is Out Of
Reach for many who now face steep
borrowing costs the bank of Canada's
interest rate that remained low and
relatively steady the last decade has
been raised five times three full points
in just over six months central banks
around the world are raising interest
rates creating an increasingly gloomy
outlook for the global economy it's
quite possible we could see a recession
in the United States and Canada being a
small open economy a trading a trading
economy we will import the weakness that
is outside of our borders as add to that
another interest rate hike expected
later this month and Canadians are in
for a bumpy ride Eric Sorensen Global
News Toronto
next I asked the governor of the Bank of
Canada how long inflation and interest
rates could keep Rising
High inflation along with Rising
interest rates are causing real
financial hardship from many Canadians
especially people on low incomes the
head of the Bank of Canada plays a key
role in managing both those things and
Tiff Macklin joins me now he's in
Halifax today Mr Maclin the bank has
faced criticism for increasing borrowing
costs at a time when we know so many
Canadians are already struggling to
afford groceries and gas and other
Essentials today you said more interest
rate Rises are coming can you say
anything to reassure Canadians I I get
it that it is a bit counter-intuitive
for raising interest rates that's
raising the cost of borrowing for
Canadians but actually that is what the
economy needs because by making
borrowing more expensive people are
going to borrow less spend less and save
more and that's going to take some of
the steam out of inflation and bring
inflation down you know last year you
predicted Rising inflation was
transitory that it would settle down
again this year inflation reached a
40-year high earlier this year what went
wrong with the central bank's forecasts
well thanks for reminding me Donna
unfortunately that turned out to be
overly optimistic this time as you'll
remember well in February Russia Russia
invaded Ukraine we saw a further
increase in these Global inflationary
pressures and inflation moved up another
leg the other thing that's happened
though more recently is that
increasingly inflation in Canada
reflects what's happening in Canada the
economy is overheated and we need to
cool the economy and that'll relieve
some of those price pressures well I
know you talk about restoring price
stability and that that's key but can
you explain in simple terms why
continuing to raise interest rates here
in Canada will contribute to that when
other factors outside the country are
stoking inflation
you're right you know the the rapid
run-up that we saw in inflation over the
last year or so was largely driven by
these Global factors higher oil prices
higher wheat prices higher prices for
many globally traded Goods bicycles
appliances
things that people really wanted during
the pandemic
those global price pressures they're
still elevated but they're starting to
ease but what we're seeing is that as
the economies reopened there's now very
strong demand for many services
Recreation tourism restaurants and
businesses are having a hard time
keeping up and that's creating domestic
inflationary pressures and by raising
interest rates we can improve that
balance between demand and Supply here
in Canada and that that'll cool those
domestic inflationary pressures that's
what we're focused on
you've raised the Bank of Canada rate
five times now since March how high
Could It Go
how high they go for how long is going
to depend on the evolution of the
economy and importantly the evolution of
inflation and what I can say is what are
some of the key things we're watching
we're watching how higher interest rates
affects demand in the economy how
rapidly is it cooling we're looking at
these Global Supply and domestic supply
issues how quickly or how slowly are
those getting resolved and the other
thing we're watching closely is
inflation expectations it's really
important those stay anchored on our two
percent Target so as those inflationary
pressures cool inflation comes all the
way back to our two percent Target a
final question the leader of the
opposition as you know has said if he
becomes prime minister he would fire you
he's accused you of shirking your
responsibility and allowing the Bank of
Canada to be what he calls an ATM for
prime minister Trudeau's spending during
the pandemic I know you've said you
don't want to comment on that but um
help me understand why you don't want to
defend yourself and and do you think
that the leader of the opposition maybe
doesn't understand stand what
instability of firing the Bank of Canada
Governor would cause we we have an
independent Central Bank for a reason in
this country and that is to control
inflation to deliver price stability and
I can tell you I go to work every day
that's my focus inflation is hurting
Canadians the best way to protect
Canadians from high inflation is to
eliminate it
all right Tiff Macklin governor of the
Bank of Canada thank you for taking time
with us
a pleasure Donna thank you
well it is that time of the year again
next what's behind our seasonal
obsession with pumpkin spice
if you love it you love it and you know
that's fine but if you happen to loathe
pumpkin spice and I'm not naming any
names here this season is a very long
one we sent Mike you're lay to sniff out
how far pumpkin spice has spread and
whether there is any squashing the
momentum
it's a nose tickling tram and Canadians
have bought in one latte at a time
forget fall it's unofficially pumpkin
spice season it wasn't so long ago we
gorge on the king of gourds through
hayrides and Halloween an attachment
born from pioneering days so there's no
practical reason to put pumpkin in your
cup of coffee to put it on your front
stoop to put sweeten it and put it in
your pie but those com those modern day
Traditions actually date that's back to
much older traditions of associating the
pumpkin with the small family farm but
oh my gourd forget hayrides it's not
fall without pumpkin spice infused
everything pumpkin spice spam may be
sold only in the U.S but if Canadians
want cream cheese Oreos even Twinkies
all infused with pumpkin spice they're
available now pumpkin spice Cheerios
that's not to say they're great or even
good those have an after kick it's
really up to the individual and if
you're sewing client you can wash it
down with a pumpkin infused craft brew
like the awesomely named Flying Monkeys
theater of Madness pumpkin lager if any
and all of that is just too scary to
contemplate the pumpkin spice season is
thankfully short until then go big or
gourd home
micro leg Global News Toronto
oh boy and if you thought we were done
with pumpkins think again tonight's your
Canada is this a gigantic gourd it's
champion of the great white North
pumpkin way off in Smoky Lake Alberta it
weighs 2 537 pounds or almost 700
kilograms it is the largest pumpkin ever
grown in Canada that's global national
for this Thursday thanks for watching
bye-bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]